from the University of Cambridge and
he's been there ever since he's now a
professor there so thanks Rajan so yeah
it's really a great pleasure to be here
so thank you very much to the organizers
together such a such a great program so
I'm going to be speaking about a topic
that's received really an enormous
amount of attention in statistics over
the last 15 or 20 years that is variable
selection it's work that is a joint work
with with Rajan like the last talk but
it builds very much on on a paper by
Nicolai Mines house and who gave the
last talk and and Peter Bowman and Peter
heard that I was speaking at 4:00 so he
decided to get an early taxi to the
airport okay so yeah I think you you
could trace it at least as the short
version of this story is you could trace
the sort of history of the recent work
on variable selection back to Rob to
Ronnies 1996 paper on the LA Zoo where
he looked at ly and penalized B squares
optimization so so tried to fit high
dimensional linear models although
perhaps he didn't have the kind of scale
of the dimension in mind that we have
nowadays but he's the sort of great
observation was that if you do this l1
penalization then you end up with some
components of your if your estimated
parameter vector being zero and so you
can do this automatic simultaneous
variable selection and parameter
estimation and then there's been that if
you sort of look at this vast body of
work that's being done since then it's
you could sort of crudely categorize it
as belonging to to two groups on the one
hand people have looked much more
general models so you go from the linear
model which is the most explicit thing
where you can make the most concrete
statement and then people have started
looking at generalized linear models or
additive models or partially linear
additive models or varying
efficient party linear additive models
generalized varying coefficient washing
linear additive models and you can sort
of imagine the way that this goes and
then on the other hand that people look
at sort of different sorts of penalty
functions you might try to use and
explore the properties that the
resulting procedures have so you go from
sort of l1 penalize regression to the
elastic net or the adaptive lassu or
scared or mCP or CeeLo there are
probably several other penalty functions
that I have either forgotten about or
unaware of some of sorry if I forgotten
someone to he's invented one here anyway
stability selection is not in itself a
variable selection method but it's it's
one that you can sort of bolt on to any
existing variable selection technique
with the idea of improving its
performance and the sort of great
advantage of it is that you can use it
in conjunction with any base variable
selection procedure and any underlying
data generating mechanism so it's
tremendously general in its
applicability the idea is very very
simple indeed it's just you apply your
favorite base selection procedure to sub
samples of the data and then you a
grenade so you you do you do this for
many different splits of the data into
sub samples and then you eventually
select the variables that keep getting
chosen over and over again on each of
these sub samples so in Nicolai and
Peter's Jerris SP discussion paper from
three years ago now they introduced this
idea and they have a particularly
attractive feature of this method where
they're able to prove a finite sample
upper bound on the expected number of
falsely selective variables you end up
with through this procedure and the idea
is that this you can use this upper
bound to
to determine the threshold of the the
proportion of times a variable has to
occur only to a subsample in order for
you to choose it eventually okay so let
me set this in a slightly more concrete
setting actually the the sort of the
model I'm assuming is very very
straightforward indeed I just assume
that I have some data and for now I'm
going to assume that these are iid
random vectors so I'm going to think of
some of the components of these random
vectors as being signal variables and
some of them as being noise variables
although rather interestingly I don't
not got to worry too much about
precisely what I mean by signaling noise
in this particular talk and I'll come
back to that point a little bit later on
once I've talked about a bit more about
stability selection but if you want
something to imagine something a little
bit more concrete you can imagine that
that our each of these random vectors
can be partitioned as a covariant and
response pair perhaps with the covariant
living in some p dimensional space where
p could be very large and a real-valued
response and you can imagine that you
have some log likelihood or pseudo log
likelihood of the form given there where
so you've got some linear predictor and
entering there entering the model here
and if that were your your model and I'm
not assuming it is it's only as an
illustration then of course your signal
variables would be the components
corresponding to have non nonzero
coefficients and the noise variables
would have zero coefficients and just so
that we can fix our terminology if I fix
a subset of the variables then my
selection sorry my signal verbs are a
subset of one up to P my set of possible
variables and noise variables as a
complement and then a variable selection
procedure is just a statistic taking
values in the set of all subsets of 1 up
to P so this is representing the
variables that are eventually choose
okay so let's write down in mathematical
terminology what we mean by stability
selection then one more piece of in
notation it'll be convenient to
introduce
if we've got a subset of one up to n so
I'm going to be subsampling rows of my
data it'll be convenient to write s hat
of a for the variables I select when I
apply my base procedure s hat subsequent
not a to that particular sub sample of
the data okay so that that's what I'll
call s hat a and then Nicola and Peter's
idea is to define this quantity pi hat
of K so for variable K pi hat of K is
the proportion of times that variable K
gets chosen over all possible splits of
the data into subsets of size n over 2
I'll say a little bit about why n over 2
in just a moment but so we're averaging
over all those possible n choose n over
2 subsets of size n over 2 that
encounter the proportion times that
variable K gets chosen and then we fixed
some threshold and we eventually keep
the variables that could get chosen a
proportion at least tour of the time so
if our thresholds tall and that's what
I'll write this superscript SS first
ability selection to denote that that's
set of selected variables okay so why n
over 2 well I don't want to claim that
this is the only thing you could do by
any means but one sort of loose
motivation for it is that you can think
of it as rather mimicking the bootstrap
so that the bootstrapping would of
course be taking resamples with
replacement here I'm thinking of
subsampling the rows without replacement
but you can imagine them both as in a
slightly more general bootstrap
framework I sort of exchanged ibly
weighted bootstrap schemes so for the
usual nonparametric bootstrap you end up
weight with with exchangeable weights
having a multinomial distribution and
come a 1 over N 1 over N 1 over N and
you can think of these these sub
sampling is also belonging to that kind
of exchange ibly weighted scheme well if
you think about
the sum of the weights is is an in both
cases the variance of the of the weights
for the nonparametric bootstrap would
would be very close to one and if you
think of subsampling then you can do a
simple calculation and show that the
variance of each weight is n over m
minus 1 and that's converging to 1 if
and only if the the subsample fraction
is converging to 1/2 so in this sense
Mike my claim is that subsampling with
some taking some samples of size n over
2 is kind of most closely mimicking the
bootstrap amongst all possible sub
sample fractions you might choose not
that necessarily that's an optimality
criterion itself it's just that we know
and trust the bootstrap so it seems like
a reasonable thing to do ok so so here
is a description of Nicolai on Peters
main result giving this finite sample
bound the final about holds under two
conditions one of which I regard is very
strong and the other is very weak so the
strong condition says that this set of
random variables is the indicator
function of whether or not variable K
gets chosen by my base procedure when K
is a noise variable that set of random
variables is exchangeable so that's
maybe a little bit hard to process what
that's meaning it's saying that the the
Joint Distribution is invariant to
permutations of those variables in
particular that would mean that they all
have the same distribution and the same
mean so that what that's saying is that
every very every noise variable would
have to have the same selection
probability and so that sort of gives
some indication as to why I regard it as
a strong condition because typically we
might well imagine that that some there
are some variables which are some noise
variables which are highly correlated
with signal variables and therefore have
a reasonably high chance of being
selected and some variables which are
not so highly correlated with signal
variables and therefore would have a
lower chance of being selected so the to
impose this
assumption that they all have the same
selection probability I think is strong
the week one just says that the the base
selection procedures not not worse than
a random guess so you end up picking at
least as much of the say at least as
much of the signal of many of the signal
variables as you would if you ignore the
data and just chosen at random so I
think that's fairly self ed and
evidently not not too strong a condition
and then so this finite sample bound
says that provided our threshold tool
this is that the threshold on the
proportion of times that a variable has
to be chosen in order to anse absorbers
in order to be chosen eventually
provided that thresholds bigger than 1/2
we can bound the full selection rate
that is the expected number of noise
variables that get chosen by stability
selection with a bound that depends on
three things here one of the interesting
things to notice immediately is that
you've got this p the dimension of the
model on the bottom of this bound so the
large of the Moral that the smaller that
the bound that's kind of interesting
because it suggests that we have some
sort of blessing of dimensionality which
is very counterintuitive to
statisticians you can explain it of
course because if you have an awful lot
of variables then it's unlikely that any
individual noise variable will keep
getting chosen often enough on it on the
sub samples to get chosen eventually by
stability selection of course you don't
really ever get a blessing of
dimensionality in statistics and and
what we're doing here is we're only
looking at one of the two types of
errors you might make so there's a false
non selection rate as well and clearly
that's going to deteriorate as P
increases but at least it on this side
of the bound for that for this sort of
bound as P increases then then you do
improve the bound so the other terms
that are involved on this right hand
side you've got the the threshold level
of appears in the bound and so the
higher the Thresh
old that the fewer variables you're
going to choose and therefore the
smaller the full selection rate and the
other quantity is the expected number of
variables that you that you choose on
each of the sub samples so that's
something that's within the
practitioners control here okay so I
like this result very much the idea is
that it can help you to choose the
tuning parameter tour so tour really is
is playing the role of the
regularization parameter that's
controlling the trade-off between false
negatives and false positives and the
idea is that you as a practitioner you
you you think about what level of false
election rate you'll be prepared to
tolerate and I think that's something
that's meaningful to a to a practitioner
as opposed to in the lasso if you ask a
practitioner what value of lambda is a
good one so here this for your data I
don't think any practitioners going to
have a clue about that so this is
something that that's meaningful for a
practitioner to kind of give some
guidance on and then you know P this is
within your control so you can choose
tor to control the the full selection
rate at at that particular desired level
okay so as I mentioned that there are
well there are three potentials or
drawbacks of actually using this result
in practice the first one is that as I
mentioned before you've got these two
conditions and one of the conditions is
is certainly a very strong one the
second one which i think is probably the
least important of the three is the fact
that in order to complete pi hat of K
we've got to compute an average over N
to n over two subsets and of course n
doesn't have to be very big like like 20
before twenty-twos ten is a really
pretty big number and this wouldn't be
feasible of course the solution to this
is is very straightforward you're just
going to take capital B subsamples but
the theory doesn't apply directly to
that version of the procedure the other
point that I think is quite important is
that the bound tends to be rather weak
so you think you're going for you think
you're tolerating one full selection but
actually you've got much better control
than you think and you pay the price on
the other side in terms of the fact you
don't select that many variables if
you're if you're not careful so you have
a high force non selection rate so these
are the the things about the methodology
and the theory that we'd like to try and
work on and improve if we can okay so
the in terms of the the first bit of the
methodology that the changes that we
propose it's just a very very minor one
just instead of taking random be random
sub-samples we're going to say well
whenever you apply your base procedure
on one sub sample of size n over two
we're also going to apply it on its
complement okay so this is why we're
going to call it complementary pair
stability selection you might as well
assume that that n is even for
simplicity and and and and that that way
we don't have to worry about integer
parts of n over two and things like that
but it's easy to get round if you if you
really want to worry about that so
having chosen all be complementary pairs
and I will explicitly now sort of
incorporate the fact that we're not
going to go through all possible
complimentary pairs but just randomly
some sample B of them then we're going
to do the same sort of thing we're going
to define pi hat B of K so this is the
proportion of times that variable K is
chosen amongst the to be some samples
and then select variables as before with
this threshold tour so we choose the
variables K that that piripi R at least
a proportion tour of the time and then
you can think about trying to prove
analogous bound on the full selection
rate
but there's a point that I want to make
before I do that and it is the way we
get around the exchangeability condition
so I want to try and remove this
exchangeability condition and so one
thought you might have is that if you're
using stability selection its contingent
on a choice of a base procedure so
you're kind of you're limited in terms
of how well you can do bye-bye
how good was the original base procedure
if your original procedure is I'm going
to do a random guess then clearly by
subsampling applying on some samples you
can't hope to do any better than a
random guess now in fact so it sort of
makes sense to define these quantities
pkn which is a probability that variable
K is chosen by our original base
procedure and so instead of trying to
estimate directly whether we have signal
or noise we're going to think about
estimating these fundamental quantities
for our CDs PK ends a selection
probability so all we can hope for by
using some stability selection type of
procedure is that by using stability
selection we end up selecting variables
that have high selection probability
under the base procedure and not
selecting the ones that have low
selection probability and the base
procedure rather than worrying about
whether we end up selecting signal or
noise because we're contingent on the
performance of the base procedure so for
us we're going to introduce a set of low
selection probability variables which
are going to be a sort of proxy for
noise and then a high selection
probability variables which of course
proxies for signal in fact what you can
imagine is that the the base procedure
is also trying to estimate this this PK
n but it's doing it with an indicator
function so it's estimating this
probability by the indicator function of
K being chosen now that's of course an
unbiased estimator because this
expectation is by definition
pkn but it's potentially got rather a
high variance what we're going to do is
we're going to be but using the sub
samples that means that each of our on
each of our sub samples we actually have
expectation PK n over two
rather than PK ends we have a biased
estimator but what we're hoping is if by
doing the averaging procedure over all
these different sub samples we can
reduce the variance and therefore end up
with a better estimator of the selection
probabilities so you can I mean the
procedure is very much like bagging or
sub bagging and it works rather well
because of the instability in the
indicator function it's it's rather a
non-smooth function and so you can do
well by averaging and the effect of the
sub sampling rather like smoothing okay
so our analog of this bound which holds
without the exchange ability and random
guessing assumptions is that the
expected number of low selection
probability variables that get chosen by
complimentary pair stability selection
can be bounded above by a quantity well
rather similar you've got the two tall
minus one as before and then on the
right hand side you've got the expected
number of low selection probability
variables chosen by the base procedure
so that's like as a sort of false
selection rate here and then you've also
got this theta appearing so theta you
want to think of as being something like
the the average selection probability
over all variables so if you use Q as I
will later on to denote that the number
that you're choosing on each of the sub
samples then you might think of theta as
being about Q over P ok so that's see
the sort of proportion of variables
you're choosing in total and that's so
if you think of that as being Q over P
then the P goes on the bottom here and
it's rather similar to the bounder that
we had before as well as the bound for
the full selection rate you've got a
bound for the other on the other side
for the false non selection rate
something that's a little bit
inconvenient for us is the fact that the
ranges of tour for which these two
bounds are valid are disjoint
you don't actually have any single value
of tour for which you have simultaneous
control of the full selection of Falls
non-selection rate that's the point I'll
come back to a little bit later in the
talk okay so let's think about how you
might apply this I don't think by any
means nowadays it's extreme to think of
P being a thousand and things only get
better for me if P appears bigger than
this but let's imagine that we choose
fifty variables on each of the sub
samples so I'll write Q for the the
number of variables chosen a sub sample
and say that's 50 so if we apply
complementary pair stability selection
with tour equals null point six which is
above our null point five minimal that
value of tour then what that's saying if
we think of theta being Q over P so tour
is not 0.6 so 1 over 2 2 minus 1 is 5
okay and theta here would be 50 over a
thousand so that'd be overall you've got
naught point 2 5 so what you're saying
is that on average you choose the
complementary pairs ability selection
chooses less than 1/4 of the low
selection probability variables chosen
by the original base procedure okay and
and that's I think I mean you could
certainly without being at all extreme
get that fraction 1/4 down to it too
much smaller things so I said as I said
you've got no exchange ability or random
guessing conditions one aspect of this
is kind of interesting is the barrel
holds even with B equals 1 so even if
you only choose one sub sample of size n
over to apply your base procedure to
that and its complement then this bound
still holds maybe that's sort of giving
you some indication that the bound could
be improved because you'd expect B to
him to appear in this bound you'd expect
to be able to do better as you choose
more and more sub samples so as when we
try and improve the bounds you'll notice
of B does enter the bound and I think
that would be more in line with what
you'd expect
but if
that there's these two conditions the
exchange ability and random guessing
conditions do hold then you can recover
something that directly controls that
the noise that the number of noise
variables that you choose
in fact the bound that we end up getting
is just a little bit tighter than the
original bound that that Nicolai and and
Peter ended up with okay so I want to be
a little ambitious and prove this bound
it's only two slides and I claim it's
really very elementary so that's why I'm
going to try and do this and also
because there's a key step in the proof
that really reveals somewhat something
to us about how we might try and seek to
improve these bounds get them tighter
and therefore get a more realistic
trade-off between false negatives and
false positives so we're going to start
by introducing this quantity PI tilde B
of K that's the proportion of times that
variable K gets chosen on each of the
complementary pairs now the reason for
using the complementary pairs is because
what goes on on one sub sample of size n
over two is independent of what goes on
on its complement so what that means is
that when we compute this expectation of
course these are this is an expectation
of identically distributed things so we
can just think about one of these
products of indicator functions but
they're independent and so the
expectation is just the probability of
choosing variable K on a subsample
squared and a key point for us is that
when K is a noise variable which is
where I'm interested in thinking about
these PK and over twos for now I expect
that the if it's a noise variable it
should have a low selection probability
so when I square it this expectation
should be really small okay so that it's
very likely that this this random
variable will be zero of course there's
a chance it'll be 1 over B a chance
it'll be to ever be a chance it will be
3 over B but these probabilities are
going to be decaying pretty fast because
this expectation is so small okay
and now we say well zero is less than or
equal to one minus an indicator function
when I multiply by another one -
indicator function it stays non-negative
and when I average over all these
different sub samples it's still
non-negative and if I multiply out that
expression I get one minus twice the the
pie hat B of K so the proportion of
times that variable K is chosen over all
the to be sub-samples plus the pie teal
tilde B of K the proportion of times I
am chosen in both halves of my
complementary pair so I want to look at
the probability that this that variable
K when K is a noise variable gets chosen
by complementary pair stability
selection that's the probability that
this proportion of times it gets chosen
is greater than or equal to tor if I
rearranged it using this this inequality
I've got here I get this thing I just
make PI tilde B of K that the subject to
that formula and now here's the key step
in the proof I apply Markov inequality
okay not a deep result for statisticians
so I've got control of this expectation
I have an exact equality for this so the
probability this tail probability is
divided it is bounded above by the
expectation divided by this this to two
or minus one let me just finish the
proof and then I'll come back to it to
that inequality so it's probably easiest
to start with here this is the thing I
actually want to control for that for
the left left-hand side of the bound I
can write that in an expectation of the
sum over all the low selection
probabilities of the indicator function
of whether or not it gets chosen in
other words the sum over the low
selection probability variables of the
this probability here now I can write
that using my markov inequality from the
previous slide in this way but then if
i'm if every k in this psalm satisfies
this this constraint then I can pull out
one of these guys as
theta out of the psalm and then the rest
of it is just putting this guy back
together like that okay so it's really
not a particularly deep result but I
still claim it's relatively useful let's
think about where we throw something
away in these inequalities so the first
is is when we when we use this this
bound here saying that this this guy is
non-negative that's not that I think the
main place where we're throwing
something away the next place is here
and I think this is really crucial
because as I said it's PI tilde B of K
this random variable here which is
supported on the set 0 1 over B 2 over
be 3 over B when K is a noise variable
it's got a very very small mean and I
imagine it's because therefore got a
high probability of being 0 a smaller
probability being won't ever be very
small probability of being too over B
and I'm asking what's the probability
it's at least naught point to say if if
tor is nor point 6 and so I want to
think therefore about when do I get
equality in markov inequality well the
equality case would be if I had a big
spike on 0 and then a sort of smaller
spike on naught point 2 with the weights
adjusted so that I match the expectation
correctly but that's not the sort of
thing that I expect to see in fact I
think I've got a a picture here where so
the black is some is a real is a
simulated situation and you see that you
do have quite a big spike or on 0 and
then these relatively quickly decaying
probabilities 1 over B 2 of B and so on
the gray is is the equality case for
Markov inequality and what you can see
is that especially on this blown-up
version where I'm looking from naught
point 2 onwards
the kind of extreme case for Markov
inequality is putting way too much mass
beyond here so the bound is very weak
and I should be able to do much better
somehow
before I come onto the somehow I just
want to so the only assumption that I
have in this analysis is that I've got
iid zetz okay so if I've got a random
design regression setting that's not a
problem but if I'm in a fixed design
situation this potentially could be a
problem because I no longer have iid
pairs but I can sort of get round these
bound the even this assumption and I can
therefore get control of the full
selection rate with no assumption
whatsoever on my data just that I have
some data so in order to do that I need
to slightly redefine what I mean by a
low selection probability variable
instead of being so so first of all I'm
going to try and get rid of the
identical distribution assumption and I
can get rid of that if I redefine ll of
theta by saying that my PK and our twos
are no longer the selection probability
of a variable K but the average
selection probability over all subsets
of size n over 2 and similarly if I want
to get rid of the independence
assumption I need to redefine the PK n
over 2 s again or as square as the
average of the simultaneous selection
probability over all possible
complementary pairs that I might choose
now if you're a skeptic like me and
someone stands up and says I can do this
with no assumptions on my data
generating mechanism whatsoever I yeah I
would tend to think well it can't be
that good at bound or something and I
think that's probably right
and that actually more useful than
trying to remove this kind of assumption
is to try and go in the other direction
and think about well if I were prepared
to make some reasonable more reasonable
assumptions about what this distribution
looks like then can I improve the bounds
that I would get from Markov inequality
and therefore improve the full selection
rate bounds so the first thing you might
think it would be reasonable to assume
that B that the disc distribution which
is supported on this lattice would be
uni-modal
okay I think that it would be very
surprising if a particular variable had
a high chance of being zero as some
neutrons have being one over B and then
a higher chance of being two over B that
would be a very very strange dependence
structure that would would lead to that
kind of distribution I think so if you
have a unimodality assumption then you
can prove a new version of markov
inequality for uni-modal random
variables supported on a lattice you
just plug that into the same and proof
that we had before and you end up with
improved bounds for the for the full
selection rate so the bounds of a
similar form you still got the theta and
you've still got this expectation here
but the constant is no longer 1 over 2 2
or minus 1 it's actually if there are
two different regimes here essentially
it's a half of what we had before for
tour between about 1/2 and 3/4 and then
it's actually even better than that for
tour between 3/4 and 1 so that's one
improvement you might make and now let's
think about going back to the same sort
of picture we had before here the black
is our simulated example showing the way
that things decay and now the gray is
showing our extremal distribution in
markov inequality if we assume unit
unimodality the extremal distribution
would again place a large mass on 0 and
then it would place non-trivial masses
flat weights from 1 over B to ever be
onwards until some point where it drops
down to 0 okay but again you can see
that's actually quite a long way off the
sort of decay that you're seeing at
least you're in the same sort of order
of magnitude now but you're quite a long
way off what you might see in practice
so you might be willing to make stronger
assumptions about the way in which this
this distribution decays and if you know
the way that my brain thinks you think
well maybe you could assume it's low
concave because I've done a lot of work
with shape restrictions and low
concavity this seems very appealing to
me and if
but if I look at this this thing that
I'd be thinking of being look on K I
mean it's an empirical average of
indicator functions so if these guys
were independent for different J then it
would have a scaled binomial
distribution that would certainly be low
concave the trouble is of course they're
not independent these these some ands
but you might still try and do it we did
try but its own turns out that in the
simulation examples that's just a little
bit too strong an assumption to make it
hasn't quite that the tail decays it
assumed is just a little bit too fast so
what we did instead was to work with
this constraint called our concavity
which sort of interpolates between
unimodality at one extreme and low
concavity at the other extreme the
precise definition of what it means to
be our concave is perhaps not
particularly relevant but I guess that
the point is that that the constraint is
becoming weaker as R is increasing to
zero so that that's like getting closer
that's like the you know modal end and
then are going down to minus infinity is
getting towards the low concavity end so
again you can do this play the same sort
of game you can prove a version of
Markov inequality for our concave random
variables and here is a bound you you
end up with now again it involves that
the B I should have mentioned perhaps
before for the unimodel bound you notice
the way that B is now entering these
bounds as we we kind of anticipated and
now the bound is a little bit less
explicit but you you can tabulate this
bound and we so it's not a problem to
use in practice it's just you don't have
a really nice clean formula for it we
did a lot of simulations with a lot of
different data generating mechanisms and
a lot of different based procedures
because of the very simple structure of
these summations of indicator functions
it seems that you're not actually that
sensitive the dependent structure is not
that sensitive to that particular choice
and so we were fairly confident in
recommending RS minus 1/2 as a pretty
safe choice
you'll be you're pretty guaranteed that
the PI tilde B of K will be our concave
with R is minus 1/2 and now you see that
the sort of extremal distribution is
much more closely matching the tail
weights you see in practice and so
you're getting a much better bound this
is a quick picture to try to convince
you that R is minus 1/2 is sensible so
if it's satisfied then these these guys
should be convex in this is just one
simulation example so of course I'm not
going to convince you totally if you're
worried about this little bit here well
this is on the probability that R minus
1/2 scale so we're we're really talking
about tiny probabilities in in the tail
at that point I'm not really too worried
about it the crosses are coming from the
extremal distribution in in markov
inequality here and this is showing the
amount of tail weight that's putting be
that that going beyond 212 minus 1 and
you can see that with minus 1/2 you're
getting much closer to what you see in
practice one further improvement of the
bounds you can make is to try to extend
things so that you can have control went
or is less than 1/2 as well as went or
is bigger than 1/2 and you can do that
by directly not not working with PI
tilde B of K but by working directly
with pi happy of K and you can play a
same sort of game assume it's minus 1/4
concave that again comes from from
simulation examples that we decided that
was reasonable and then you get two
different bounds here and and both are
valid if both the assumptions are valid
here so you can work with the minimum
and so you in total you end up with this
picture showing the improvement in the
bounds that you get so here's the
original bound that the niccola and
Peter had here's our worst case bound
just a little bit better no assumptions
whatsoever here's our you know modal
bound and here's our our concave bound
you can see this this small kink here
this is where the minimum is going from
being attained from one factor to the
odd to the other factor there and the
solid line here is showing the
this is something you see from an
empirical thing just showing that the
error bound is pretty close for a
reasonably wide range of tour this is in
no way optimized to try to be as bad as
possible of course we want this to work
for all data generating mechanisms and
all base selection procedures so
presumably there would be choices we
could make that would get us much closer
to this this upper bound here
okay okay okay so here is a quick
simulation study as I said we really did
a lot of different examples but I just
want to show one to give the sort of
flavor of the results here you've got a
linear model and we're going to put a
Tirpitz design structure on the
covariance matrix of the design
variables we're going to assume that
that the signal has got a sparsity level
s and we choose the let the signal
magnitudes in a particular way so that
between minus 1 and minus 1/2 and half
of them between 1/2 and 1 and we are
going to have n is 200 and peers are
thousands so we'll fix the LA Zoo is our
base procedure and we're going to
compare methods that control this the
full selection rate at level L okay and
the way that was suggested in Nicola and
Peters paper to control this at level L
is to choose Q the number of variables
you are choosing on each of the sub
samples to be the square root of naught
point eight times L times P and then
choose tor equals naught point nine and
the reason that works is because you
remember you've got Q squared in the
numerator of our bound so that gives us
nine point eight times L times P and
then the denominator of AB and you've
got 1 over 2 2 or minus 1 + 1 / 2 2
minus 1 that'll cancel the naught point
8 and then you also had a P on the
denominator so that cancels and that
means that that you are controlling that
the full selection rate at level L so so
that with for the worst case bound we're
going to choose tor is not 0.9 but we're
going to look at other ways you might
choose
tore one is to two to use our our
concave bound and another way is to
choose an Oracle bound that gives exact
that gives equality here so we're using
the the the sort of known simulation
structure to do some preliminary
simulations work out what an Oracle
would choose tour star to be which is
certainly going to be better than our
taught tilde here
unless of course our bound is invalid
and the are concave assumption is wrong
but but it's not and the other thing
we'll compare with is just not doing
stability selection at all but just
using the vanilla lassu and we'll give
the the lasso a particular advantage in
that will will allow that to use an
Oracle tuning parameters so that's
really quite a big advantage because
that's
I think the main aspect of complementary
pairs stability selection or vanilla
stability selection is its generality in
the sense that you can use it with any
base selection procedure and any
underlying data generating mechanism and
it's got this attractive feature that
you can bound the low selection and the
average number of low selection
probability variables you end up
choosing in a way that is meaningful to
to a practitioner and so you can you can
improve these bounds if you're prepared
to make various shape restrictions on
the underlying distribution and that
allows the practitioner to go back and
choose the this threshold in an
effective way okay thank you
yeah so so we do have this bound on it
on the other for the other type of error
here now this is a worst case bound
under no assumption I think that's quite
a week now but but it least gives you
some control there yeah I guess you kind
of hope that you choose a sensible
restarting based procedure then if
you've got a tight bound on the full
selection right you shouldn't be tuned
too badly on the full-on selection
that's that's I guess the idea
aha well I suppose yes I mean you can
just you can weaken you can choose the
thresholds and as you like to try to get
subsets
he also means that I'm every - anyone
so you have a look what's D here what is
T user dimension on the city's exciting
mom okay
yeah okay okay
let's chat a bit later yeah